hey guys it's justine and today i am so
excited for this video because i am
going to try to attempt to get out of a
straight jacket you might be like
justine why are you doing that and to
that i'm like you know what why not how
do you feel
i feel good you feel good about that
yeah i have been such a huge fan of
magic and just the whole culture around
it since i was very very young i
actually used to want to be a magician
but it really didn't end up working out
very well for me i kind of found video
games and juggling instead of magic but
i've still always loved it so when i
partnered with nordvpn to do a video i
thought what could i do so what nordvpn
is is able to encrypt your network
traffic so you're untraceable on public
wi-fi you can secure up to six devices
at the same time on almost any device
android iphone mac os linux pretty much
anything that you're surfing the web or
you're connected to you can secure it
another cool thing is you can get around
a country specific content blocks or
laws they have over 5100 servers in 62
different countries if you guys want
more information i will put a link in
the description and you can check it out
but now i want to introduce you guys to
magic murray i'm so excited for this
video he came all the way from vegas to
be in this video today so let's go hang
out with magic murray i'm so excited to
be here this is amazing you just drove
in from vegas to be here right now thank
god i didn't walk so yes i left like
four in the morning and i beat traffic
until i got to l.a because you never
beat traffic in l.a you don't because
there's traffic all the time no matter
when where it's crazy in vegas you do a
show there tell them a little bit yeah i
got a show at the tropicana hotel at the
laugh factory we do it six uh six days a
week i actually have these two weeks off
because it's the slower time just for
christmas and then it's really busy so i
kind of bounce around do some video
that's why i'm here well i was talking
to you guys about nordvpn which i feel
like a lot of people have this false
sense of security when they're on the
internet because you think you're
anonymous you think everything is safe
so i thought i was kind of relating that
sort of like in a straight jacket type
scenario okay i wanted to try to get out
of one and see if i could do it i
brought my straight jacket with me just
for you i told you earlier that i used
to want to be a magician when i was
younger i know i didn't know that's
amazing i love magic i'm just so
fascinated by all of it and used to
juggling i still do juggle i'm excited
about it i want to see you juggle later
i'd like to juggle this can
yeah when you're in it you probably
can't do much so put your arms through
those two sleeves is there any like
historic facts about straight jacks not
on this it's just it's really old and
smelly so
let me move my microphone all right this
is the magic behind the scenes magic you
guys how long have you been straight
jacketing uh well for a few years now
for a few years it's a bit of an
addiction but you know so now what
happens we we do this up in the back
right yeah that goes in the buckle there
goes this little thing here see so
that's locked in there like this is a
bit large for you because you're so tiny
so thank you i'll take the flattery
do you think i'll be able to get out you
might be altered actually
so is there like a special technique so
if you ever find yourself in a straight
jacket that you know people might want
to
think about yes the technique is really
try hard okay that's it
are you left-handed or right i'm
right-handed actually but when i play
sports i uh if i play baseball i hit the
ball in the left-hand person we are
opposite because i write left-handed but
i play all sports right arms
okay should we show them what's
happening back there
all right you all right yeah you're good
okay i just want to make sure it's time
no it's okay i'm just being dramatic how
do you feel
i feel good hang on i'm gonna get
twisted like a press get ready yeah
three two one are you ready yes three
two one go
i should have watched some youtube
videos before this go right i messed up
you push your leg through there am i
supposed to try it my dog has peed and
pooed all over this place nice this
could be a new yoga thing actually this
could be actually a new yoga thing this
is good okay
namaste do you feel houdini like
a little bit
is this we're gonna go for lunch and
then when we come back you want anything
while we go out
am i doing should i should i do
something differently wait
i've done something i've done something
yeah okay but now my hand is twisted
this looks like something i should do
this is great
nice so now we gotta do is get your
other arm over your head other arm over
my head this one or this one uh probably
your right one
okay
excellent so how do you feel about that
it's like now i'm just twisted behind
myself try to unbuckle the one from here
the two that are attached behind you now
get them in front of your face and use
your teeth to pull off the uh the buckle
so my hands are here now you gotta get
them
that's right so you want to get your
teeth on that button okay well but your
face this is the wrong way
my face is over here
perfect things that i did which is great
gotten myself into a pickle
how'd you get your hands behind you
that's what i want to know
no i have a hand yes you do so unbuckle
the uh the back strap see this is
definitely i'm definitely cheating
because i
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah for my final
trick
let me see there you go see now you got
it i'll just pull it that way to the
right and then once it pops off
oh my
gosh i
yes here it comes they're gonna make it
very dramatic you gotta swing it around
not lose it yeah and swing those not you
the jack
that's it you nailed it only two hours
great
you nailed it wow i can't believe it i
thought it was actually going to be
stuck in it so do you want to show the
proper way sure
what are the neighbors things you know
looking at going well oh no little
gardening yeah they moved out um okay so
i don't want to hurt you i think i think
this is way more tighter on me than it
was i'm just gonna throw it out there
for sure three
two
one okay here we go
oh you're doing some things
i made it super tight whoa
okay so that's
something i should have done
you go you just let me get on the ground
yeah and roll around like a fool when i
could have done this
so you have to really sell it yet you
sold it i can't believe you let me roll
around on the grass it was great that
was worth the whole price of coming uh
driving or driving to l.a but i did get
out of it
i know so you also brought something
else too yes oh what did you bring let's
let's go
do you have a lighter at all or anything
on you i know you have a flamethrower
would you have a lighter lighter okay
you're ready watch carefully ready nice
good it's windy
hold on it's like is this the trick
did you make wind happen i know right
nailing it this is great okay whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa isn't that cool it's not
about deck cards
so let's do a trick
they came with a lighter
so let's do you wanna see a trick yeah
all right so i'm still processing
so those normal deck cards yes yes and
we're gonna see they're different yeah
different oh what's a good card in the
deck like if you're playing like in
vegas what's it what are these um
ace do you like aces yeah let's do this
and cut the bag once twice a few times
all right and say stop whenever you want
stop right there great take the card
hang on to it
look at it
show the camera
is that a nice perfect okay good so
that's one yeah you can show me it's
okay oh okay perfect i see the trick so
perfect
let's cut them back how many times do
you want to cut the deck once twice
three times yeah two two yeah i'd like
it all right once twice like that take
the card
show the camera excellent there's your
second exercise
perfect look at that no
i got an idea so let's um
let's check this out uh top card here is
jack of what um
very good
take it off
excellent there's the third egg
no what is happening in my small mind
what's the what's the other um
ace we need each other camera we need we
did it these are spades yeah so that's
the hardest one really
but it's the most active one
super action
no oh my gosh
yeah where did he come from
i do you could have picked any card you
said she said two sevens what you said
did you know i was going to take this is
a plan does it sound mentally after
watching your demonstration the straight
jacket of it this is what she's going to
pick i felt it oh wait this is so cool
try something let's do this red black
red black right so let's
um
top card
uh what color uh red red hold it
don't move keep that there watch it all
right bottom card what color
keep that there put your hands on top of
the two red cards go back and forth make
sure you not see how it was too much oh
no no because they're here no no yeah no
that's what happened so you rub them too
hard you rub them way too hard you gotta
you gotta be gentle you gotta be nice
with them
yeah what how did they what is it i know
so you wanna see something really cool i
brought yes so i brought some because i
know we're talking with houdini and all
the stuff that he does and all that but
i actually have a pair of unions
handcuffs from 1915. no way do you want
to see them yes i do they're right there
here i'll bring them over
back in the day they're worth about uh
two dollars and fifty cents back in
ninth and now they're worth about eight
thousand five hundred dollars oh my gosh
price of a starbucks girl
so there they are
you have a key really cool so these are
called the darby style of handcuffs just
for you know historical i love his
history stuff you know your hands would
go through here and the bar would
separate your wrists now back that was
back in the day nowadays they have a
chain so if you see look at the key it's
cylindrical so there's nothing really
identifying right because it's a hollow
key
so so what happens it goes into here and
then there's a bar in here and that goes
over the bar spins the bar down it locks
it down
and then to get the key back out you
have to back turn the key so it looks
like you're undoing the handcuffs you're
not though you're taking the key off the
bar and that's how these work so um you
want to lock me up hanging out
okay and hold it together make sure it's
nice and tight that's it go for it
there you go
and then that's locked in
good now pull on those make sure they're
locked oh i'm making sure yeah pulling
okay yeah you're in there you're happy
with that yeah yeah locked yeah yeah all
right i just want to make sure okay good
i'll come back with the face um so let's
see the hairpin you got a hyphen yes
okay sorry you can count how fast i can
get it okay um
one
two
[Music]
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
[Music]
oh man i was just about to say this is a
discount hairpin
that's amazing i mean what
made you want to
do that
jail time okay
well thank you so much for coming here
and doing some tricks for me we're gonna
also do a video on his channel so i'm
super excited to show you guys that i'll
put all these links in the description
you have to go check them out subscribe
go say hi and if you guys love magic
here you go
here's your man thank you thank you
[Music]
so
you